[Applause]
Irene Cara has died she was 63 years old
there really aren't any categories you
know there's soul and rock and they both
have fed off each other for years and
that's how I approach my music a rep for
the blood performer confirmed the news
on Saturday Irene died at her home in
Florida her cause of death is unknown at
this time
[Music]
and in the wake of Irene's death stars
are paying tribute
[Music]
please believe
[Music]
a high point for Irene's career was
performing and co-writing the title song
for Flash Dance I just had the impact
that I had and I'm grateful for it I
know that being a part of
projects like Fame and Flashdance really
brought a new Awakening to the
Performing Art here and throughout the
world Irene won a Grammy and an Academy
Award for the 80s Anthem I felt terrific
I'm very happy Jennifer Beals who played
the lead role in Flashdance thanked
Irene for her open heart and fearless
Talent quote it took a beautiful dreamer
to write and perform the soundtracks for
those who dare to dream and one of those
was John Leguizamo who said Irene made
me believe if you were Latin you could
make it she fueled my community you know
I've never been one to you know be pushy
and bang on doors to be a celebrity you
know I've always been an artist since I
was a child and I've been in this
business since I was a child even as a
youngster I wrote my music and my lyrics
When I was a kid I was saying recognize
your power take your dreams and make it
happen as Lenny Kravitz put it Irene
defined an error
wanna keep it in the groove by the time
Flashdance came along in 1983 Irene had
been working for over a decade in 1976
she took on the title character in
Sparkle
but Irene wasn't just a main Stan the
Silver Screen she also earned critical
Acclaim on TV I think my favorite cast
would have to be Roots the Next
Generation I think it's a mock of a
particular dear friend to point out
false it felt like the closest thing I'd
ever get to doing Shakespeare but it was
Irene's performance as Coco Hernandez in
Fame that made a lasting impact on a
generation you know this was a school
that I got into
in junior high that I was never able to
go because I worked I remember just
feeling well I finally get to go to this
school and that's really what it felt
like
[Music]
Debbie Allen who starred in the original
flick as well as the famed TV series
said Irene's music will live forever
everything
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]